then they've got two activated hand
grenades
in my hands which i didn't know what it
means activated or anything he says
you hold this tight and if you let it go
you blow yourself and you blow the rest
of your family
[Music]
when did you start to notice that things
were beginning to change
in bosnia i came to school and it was in
may
two weeks prior to the war starting
in kosarat i came to school and i've
seen my teacher
with a full uniform and kalashnikov
on the desk pointing at me
so i said to the teachers so what
why are you wearing a uniform why is the
gun
pointed at me and he says are you scared
because i'm a serp she's scared i'm
gonna kill you and
everything was thrown at me i was only
13 i said
i don't know that you're a serb i
thought we're all the same
around the area where we were a lot of
houses were getting destroyed it felt
like
for some reason she didn't reach our
village yet um
and we've been told the minute when
we've been told them
the troops the ground troops are
entering the village i think that's when
the horror started
the particular morning it was a sunny
morning
and um all i can hear is
that the military van coming
and my mom wrote to me and then my
father came he says look
you might be questioned don't say
nothing it's like
whoa what's this what if these guys
threatened to kill me
he said you know whatever they say to
you
even if they have to kill you don't say
nothing and that's stuck in my head
before your night they they've turned up
we were all outside of the house when um
there's a group of six of them
just when they reached me my father was
next to him my mom was on the side
my dad whispered to me say do not look
at them in their eyes because as they're
looking i started looking at them and
says do not look at them in their eyes
and i was there the best advice i had
from my father
you know i didn't know the time but
i think it's um you become a witness and
that the chances are surviving so you
you look at someone you remember the
face and they'd have to kill you because
you've become a witness that in future
can recognize them so
avoiding an eye contact it's bust they
um
stripped me naked in front of
26 family members and
i was tortured it started with um
they put me on execution spot and
they've asked me simple questions do you
know
if anybody um
distributed the the weapons
to the people in the village for
territorial army i said
just raising my hands
um and they put me on an execution but
he says if you don't tell us you'll have
three chances we'll shoot you
and um all three chances i i kept
quiet whilst dad was right in front of
me
when it put me on execution spot i was
away from a moment
for my mom the rest of the family only
me and dad were were taken behind the
bushes but they can hear me they were
literally around the corner
and my mom taught at this point where
the first bullet went they've they've
killed me
and then they shot above my head and the
second bullet and the third bullet
i think the soldier knocked the barrel
so he missed me
then they've got two activated hand
grenades in my hands
which i didn't know what it means
activated or anything he says you hold
this tight
and if you let it go you'll blow
yourself and you'll blow the rest of
your family
and and and i held it so tight that
like my life depends on it i wasn't sure
if
if the pins were taken out or not um
but i was convinced the pins were out
all of this only by when the soldier
took it off me
the concentration in his hands um
they were activated and grenades for
given to 13 years old child
then that wasn't enough they started
beating me with a buckle of a belt the
army buckle of a belt
then they took a knife and they made
crosses here which is
still a little bit you can see here
and then i've got crosses on my chest
all with blood
beating started um
the rifle bot um
and he lasted for a couple hours he was
probably the the longest couple hours in
my
in my life until i started gushing the
blood started coming out of my mouth and
nose they've stopped
i heard one soldier saying we will come
back to kill you
and i i
was lying down in a pond of blood
and what's interesting then
the parents the family members were
scared to come near me
for a very long time you know um
until until the the soul just
drove off you mentioned um
an old school teacher who was a serbian
teacher
is that the person who tortured you
that's the person that came around with
the rest of the soldiers
can you explain to us about why he did
those things to you
i don't know i i guess um
because he he loved me so much and then
he found out
throughout the war that when the war
kicked off that we were different and we
were enemies so all of a sudden if you
were serb and
the other person is a bosnian and the
other person would croat
you became an immediate enemy
what happened to you and your family
after you experienced that first torture
the shelling in in in our village and
around villages
stopped after a couple of weeks and then
the troops went down
so they were surrounding the villages
they were ethnically cleansing the whole
area and they were putting us into
concentration camps so there was a
keratin concentration camp there was a
miniature there was turnover
and we we've fallen into the
concentration cup called tenopoly which
was my school
and some of the guards were our teachers
how did you and your family end up
fleeing the concentration camp
we got an auntie that lives in croatia
so um my dad um
found a way of getting us through his
friend
to croatia where we found refuge
only for a short period of time
in um auntie's house in croatia first
time
i experienced the nightmares
so i um had a soldier shouting
will come back to kill you then my dead
family members are coming
in front of me calling him to join them
the real nightmares with sleeping part
and start affecting me but
we you know we just saw the child my my
mom tour the child
is having a bad dream about the war
i didn't know anything about mental
problems or ptsd until we
we came to uk can you
explain what it was like when you
traveled to the uk
we we came by coach so two colleges were
sent from uk um
to collect those refugees we we stayed
in birmingham central mosque
um and and that's where um it was uh
a refuge for time being until they found
us housing
i remember the doctor turning up to the
mosque
he straight away said to my parents that
um
i will suffer with with a mental problem
for the rest of my life he'll never be
a normal child he'll never be able to
follow education
he'll never be able to have a proper job
or he'll never be able to have kids
and that really hit me hard
one day the the the teacher
mr fatca spotted me um i want a couple
of boys are
kicking my head in whilst i was on the
floor
and um they took me and said what's
going on and
they've realized i don't even speak and
most of the time people say it doesn't
speak because it doesn't speak english
but there's more to it the school took a
real interest
and one of the teachers said to me
how about you turning up to assembly and
speaking
in front of you year ahead um
and just saying a few things what
happened to me
and i felt you know after the war what
i've been through
and it was probably the biggest
challenge that i've faced
it was the biggest challenge for me
receiving that pain from the bullies
but going and talking facing the bullies
and talking he
was a nightmare um but i said i owe
something to the teachers i must put a
lot of effort
so it was a morning assembly um friday
end of the week i always remember
and i said i
war problem bosnia
soldier killed
my family i no like
war no weapon
i was looking at a sheet of paper though
wrought and i read all night and
all day to get myself prepared and ready
and so concentrating to get these words
out to pronounce them because
pronunciation was a nightmare
and i looked around and
every single person in that room
including teachers were crying
you know you see a bullies they've done
really bad things to me in school
as they do they're crying you know so
it's the first time i felt compassion
i felt somebody's listening
somebody's understanding me do you think
13 year old you would have expected
that you have got where you have now
even today i really felt
that my family brother and assistant
mom and dad been through so much
but having said that they feel so proud
of me now
i achieved so much and i have my own
family i have my own kids i have a boy
and a girl
and my wife a wonderful wife
and um people ask me we've been through
that
and you've earned a bit of money you've
got stability
but i want to lead this world by by
giving a good example of being a good
role model
so when people see me they just see me
as
um i i do everything
to demonstrate what it means to be good
people good citizen
of this world and to share this world
with harmony and peace
in my little world i want to bring
the people together with
our similarities rather than our small
differences
and because of what happened in the
school in bosnia
and how i was treated in a school in uk
i wanted to become a teacher to
teach the world the normal teachers
don't do those things what i have
experienced
[Music]
pamphlet was once handed to me outside
the clinic that said women who have
abortions are more likely to
sorry are more likely to sexually abuse
their children
and women are receiving this information
trying to access healthcare